翻訳: erika shimatani
校正: Koichiro YODA
（赤ちゃんの泣き声）
（拍手）
皆さん この状況
どんな状況か分かりますか？
何をしても一向に泣き止まない
赤ちゃんの泣き声です
24時間365日 我が子優先の生活です
オムツかな？ お乳かな？ お熱かな？
何をしても泣き止まない我が子です
外出は公園とスーパー
会話するのは近所の人か パートナーか
ごく限られた人たちです
自分自身も目一杯になって
「ちょっと助けて」って言う声さえ
上げられない状況でした
自分だけが社会から
取り残されているような感覚に陥る
こんな毎日がいつまで続くんだろう？
そこまでだったらいいんですけど
ママって誰かのせいにしだすんですね
「旦那のせいだ」とか
「近所の人のせいや」って
「なんで私ばっかり」って
こういう状況です
これが本当にママの置かれている
現状ではないでしょうか
私の独身時代と
子どもを産んでからの24時間表です
比べてみると本当に
自分の時間っていうのはほとんどありません
出産後ですが見てください
２〜３時間毎の授乳 小刻みの睡眠時間
24時間それを繰り返します
その時に赤ちゃんが寝ない時があるので
ずっと横抱きで
私も長男 目の前にいるんですけど
長男をこうやって横抱きにしていた時に
腱鞘炎になってしまって
テーピングを貼って痛いのに
治らないままにまた抱っこするみたいな
生活を繰り返ししていました
その間に「寝たな」と思って
寝かしつけておいて
「家事しようかな」と思ったら
また起きてしまう
夜までたっても家事が終わらない
っていうような状況で
それを言い訳に
仕事から帰ってきた旦那さんに
「あぁ ごめん 子どもが全然言うことを
聞いてくれへんかってん」って言って
また人のせいにするっていうような生活です
そんな忙しい毎日がずーっと続くんです
でも ママたちは
「社会と繋がりたい」
「社会の役に立ちたい」って
ずっと思っているんです
現在 日本では
出産を機に仕事を辞めてしまう女性が
６割以上いると言われています
［出産を機に仕事を
辞めてしまう女性 60％］
でも ママたちは「働けない」ではなく
「働かない」という選択をしていることに
気付いているんですね
で 働かない理由が３つあります
まず１つ目は
「かわいい盛りの我が子を預けてまでも
働きたくない」という理由です
私も今２歳の子どもがいるんですけど
本当に０歳から３歳までの
かわいい盛りっていうのは
「子育てって本当に期間限定だ」って
子育て終わった大先輩から
よく言われたりするんですけども
「この子の成長を今 子の側で
見ておきたいな」っていうのが
親の願いではないでしょうか
２つ目の理由が
「保育園料や病気のことで
立場的に不利になる」ということです
時給と保育園料を払ったら
バランスが悪くなってしまって
ママってよく
「何のために働いてるんやろう？」って
時短でしか働けなくなってしまうんですね
そんな時にせっかく働いたのに
病気や発熱とかで緊急事態で
呼ばれることがあります
緊急事態で呼び出しが来たら
なんか職場の人たちに
「すみません 子どもの保育園から
急に熱が出たって言ってるので
迎えに行かないといけません」って
「申し訳ないです」っていうふうな形で
職場の人たちにこうやって
頭を下げないといけません
そうなってきたら なんか
「周りの人に迷惑かけるんやったら
私が今 子供を保育園に預けずに
自分で見て
その方が迷惑かからへんし
その方がいいんちゃうかな？」っていう
選択をしているお母さん多いと思います
３つ目が「夫の扶養の範囲内で働きたい」
っていう声も本当によく聞きます
私も色々 働き方を模索してきました
長男が１歳７か月の時に
フィットネスのインストラクター
という資格を取って
その仕事につきました
最初は本当に子連れで手を引いて
そこそこ楽しくやっていたんですけど
急に本当にその仕事を
もっともっと深めたいなと思いだして
子どもを預けて
フィットネスクラブで働くようになりました
実際に子どもを預けて
働いてみたんですけど
本当に急な呼び出しやったりとか
10時から16時くらいまでしか
働けないとか
上の子ができたら もう
15時には幼稚園のお迎えがいるから
そこに戻らないといけない
っていうような形で
子育てと仕事のバランスっていうのが
本当に上手く取れなかったです
妊娠を機にその仕事も辞めました
で 妊娠して
「もう働き続けられる形はないかな？」
っていうふうに
ずっと模索をし始めました
ちょうど次女が生まれたときに出会ったのが
「ママの働き方応援隊」
通称「ママハタ」という仕事でした
このママハタは
「子育て中がメリットになる働き方を作る」
というミッションを掲げていて
私はそのワードにビビビっときました
「これなら子供と一緒に働ける！」
「仕事を通して社会と繋がれる！」
って思ったんですね
そのママハタの取り組みの一つが
「赤ちゃん先生プロジェクト」
というものです
小学校から高齢者施設
行政や企業に出向いて
様々なプログラムを提供しています
たとえば 高校 大学では
学生さんたちに
「結婚 出産を含めたキャリアデザイン」
っていうものを考えてもらっています
そうしたら女子学生が言うんですね
「私はキャリアの邪魔になるので子供は
産みません」って言っていた女子大学生が
赤ちゃん先生受講後
「あ！ 結婚 出産もありかも！
なんだかそれらを含めたキャリアデザインも
考えてみようと思います」って
言われたりします
ある時 男子学生は
「僕は就職は大企業しか考えていません
でも お母さんたちの話を聞いたときに
地域の企業でもいいかなって
その方がパートナーと子育て
手伝えたりするから楽にできるのかも」
っていう言葉も もらったりします
他にも 行政や企業に出向いたりもします
たとえば 商品開発やイベントの企画など
お手伝いをしているんですけども
実際に現場に行くと
子連れっていうのは本当に厳しくて
どんな声が出てくるかっていうと
これですね
「子連れで何ができる？」
「母親は子育てに専念するものだろ」
「子どもを犠牲にしてまでも働きたいの？」
「子連れでなんて考えが甘い」
っていうような言葉を
相手から言われることは
本当に多々ありました
社会の子連れに対する
壁の厚さにぶち当たって
その度に凹み 涙することが多々あります
「まだまだ子連れの人が働くっていうのは
周りの理解が低いんだな」っていうのを
ひしひしと感じています
そうは言ってもこのような取り組みを
ずっと６年間ぐらい続けてきて
ママ本来の能力に気付き始めた
企業さんも結構あります
男社会とは違う物の見方をするママによって
色んなことが生まれているんですね
たとえば イベントとか
よく手伝ったりするんですけど
ママたちって
「一番消費者に近い存在」と言われています
企業担当者の方からママたちに
事前にレクチャーを受けて
そのママたちはその事前に
レクチャーで受けたことを
消費者目線で自分の言葉にして
お客様に伝えることができます
そうすると お客様もすごく安心して
「あぁ これすごい良いものなんだ！」
って思って下さったりします
使い方の工夫までアドバイスしたりします
そういう働き方を見てると
企業の担当者から
「ママすぐ ちょっとうちの会社に
働きに来てくれへん？
子ども連れて来てもええから
託児所ないけど」みたいな言葉を
よく言われたりします
実際にイベントで携わったママが
本当に担当企業のところに
本格的に就職することも出てきています
もう１つは 実際にファミリー向けの商品を
男性が企画していたりするので
ここをママ目線でアドバイスしたりも
させて頂いてます
ホームページだったり
チラシだったりに反映できて
反響が出たっていう声も
頂いたりもしています
［凝り固まっていた考えがほぐれた
反響があり驚いている］
実際にママと仕事をすることで
当初のネガティブなイメージも払拭されて
ママの能力などを理解してくれる
クライアントさんが増えてきています
行政や企業に出向く時は
名刺を持って
自分の名前を名乗ったりします
ママになると「○○ちゃんのママ」で
私はずっと13年間「何々くんのママ」
「何々ちゃんのママ」って
子ども４人いるので
ずっと言われ続けました
で ママって呼ばれていると
本当に自分のアイデンティティを
見失ってしまうんですね
ふと自分の名前を呼ばれたときに
振り向けないぐらい
自分って何者なのかっていうのを
見失いがちになります
この活動を機に
名刺を持ったママたちが言うんです
「久しぶりに自分の名前
フルネームで名乗りました
いつぶりですかね？」っていうふうに
喜んでる姿を見るのが
私は本当にとっても好きです
自分の仕事となると
やっぱり自分自身の名前を
名乗りながら仕事をしていくので
自分自身のアイデンティティっていうのが
本当に戻ってくるんだなっていうことを
体感しています
この写真なんですけど
なんの時か分かります？
契約書ベースで仕事をしているんですけど
契約も自分で進めていくんですね ママが
で 契約を取り付けました
契約を取り付けたら
「うわ！よっしゃー！」って
「でも めっちゃこれ責任重いやん」
っていうふうに
いつもママたちから声が上がります
自分の中で仕事っていうのが
自分ごとになって位置付けられて
しっかりと自立していくっていうところが
私はそこがすごく大事だなと思っています
このように 子育て真っ最中で
あるにも関わらず
ママも仕事を通して成長できるのです
このような成長を促すために
実は ママハタの中には
「ポジション」という考え方があります
私も順番にステップ１から
踏んできたんですが
ステップが上がるにつれて
人に会う数が全然違うんですね
実は子育て真っ最中だと
公園とか 幼稚園ママ
保育園ママっていう形で
子育て中のお母さんとのコミュニティは
すごくあるんですけど
全然違う価値観の人たちと
出会うことっていうのは
まず子育て中では難しいなと思っています
様々な価値観の人と
数多く出会うことによって
私自身も本当に仕事を通して
自分の成長を実感しています
ママは子育てについて
社会の中や地域の中で
解決していくべきことを
感覚を通して知っています
たとえば ベビーカーを押していて
段差に気付いたりとか
物を買っても
「使い勝手が悪いな」と思ったら
それを工夫して
どうやったら使い勝手が良くなるかとか
っていうふうなことを
いつも工夫を積み重ねた生活をしています
本当に子育て期間限定と言われてますが
気付くことがすごく多いんですね
私も子どもがいなければ
気付かなかったことっていうのは
この39年生きてきて
本当にたくさんあったなと
今 振り返るとよく思います
そうして気付いた地域や社会の課題を
ビジネスとして解決する
ママの社会起業家が増えたら
本当に世の中も変わると
確信しています
今の状況を変えるのは
一番の当事者であるママたちの
声や行動が鍵になると思っています
私はこの６年間で
ほんと子どもを連れながら
北海道から沖縄まで
全国を渡り歩きました
その中で 子育て中のお母さん
2,000名ぐらいの方たちの
リアルな声を聞いてきました
「社会と繋がりたい」
「子供と一緒に何かしたい」
「誰かの役に立ちたい」
っていうやる気のあるママが
本当に日本には
山ほどいるんだなっていうことを
なんかこのまま
このママたちを眠らしているのは
もったいなすぎるって
本当に心から思います
これは本当に日本にとっても
大きな損失になるんじゃないかなって
実際 私は「私なんて」
「私なんかが」って
毎日不安で自信がなかった
でも そんな自分だから
伝えたいことがあります
自分自身の可能性に気付いて
一歩を踏み出す勇気と行動が
誰かの役に立つっていうことです
目の前の人を笑顔にできるっていうことです
私自身 本当に子連れだと
働けないって思ってました
赤ちゃんの存在っていうのは
制限だと思っていました
自分の時間も無くなるし
でも なんか制限されていたり
ちょっとした負荷がかかっている方が
人のパフォーマンスがあがる
っていうことも体感しました
自信（が無い）っていうのは
本当に経験の無さなんだなっていうことも
自身で体感してきました
でも 皆さんに最後に
メッセージを伝えたいと思います
制限されているっていうことは
視点を変えられたら
新たな価値になるのではないでしょうか
ご清聴ありがとうございました
（拍手）